no
[Música]
a escala en parís
braulio moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español el pasado domingo 6 los
mexicanos acudieron a las urnas en lo
que son las elecciones más grandes en la
historia de ese país 15 gobernadores
estuvieron en juego la totalidad de la
cámara de diputados- elecciones
municipales también en total más de 20
mil cargos que estuvieron en disputa
esas elecciones sirvieron también para
medir el grado de confianza que la
población mexicana tiene en el actual
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
quien llegó a la presidencia en 2018 así
como en su organización política el
movimiento de renovación nacional morena
para hablar de esos resultados de que se
espera de cuáles son las perspectivas
saludamos aquí en nuestro estudio a
gaspar estrada director de el lokpal que
el observatorio político para américa
latina y el caribe
gaspar bienvenido a esta escala en parís
hola hablarle un gusto estar contigo el
contra auditorio gracias por
acompañarnos gaspar estrada en estas
elecciones el punto fundamental eran las
elecciones a la cámara de diputados
diputados del nivel federal que además
hay que recordar permitieron hasta el
pasado domingo mantener al movimiento
morena y sus aliados políticos la
totalidad la mayoría absoluta la mayoría
calificada desde ese congreso el
presidente ha perdido con estas
elecciones la mayoría 43 diputados de
distritos de distritos perdón de
proporción relativa han sido ganados por
la oposición esto representa un golpe
fundamental para la política del
presidente lópez obrador bueno yo creo
que hay que poner las cosas en su
contexto efectivamente estas elecciones
de medio mandato significaban un
referendo sobre la acción del gobierno
de lópez obrador
yo creo que los resultados son un poco
digamos contrastados en el sentido que
por un lado efectivamente el número de
diputados de morena disminuye y esta man
mayoría calificada desaparece es decir
será más difícil ahora a partir de ahora
para el presidente de lópez obrador
poder aprobar reformas constitucionales
si no tiene el apoyo de algunos
diputados de otros partidos por fuera de
su coalición sin embargo en el plano
territorial y sobre todo en el plano
nacional lo que sí me parece claro es
que morena se vuelve la fuerza política
dominante en el país eso se ve en
particular en los estados ya había 15
elecciones a gobernador y en este caso
pues dos terceras partes de estos de
éstas gobernaturas en juegos fueron
ganadas por momentos me parece que si la
implantación nacional de morena se
refuerce se vuelve algo muy claro a
partir de ahora pero también me parece
que el recado ha sido
bastante claro hacia el gobierno y las
críticas que puede haber hace el
gobierno y eso me parece que los
resultados de la ciudad de méxico y del
estado de méxico van en ese sentido con
una buena parte de las alcaldías de la
ciudad de miami eran gobernada pasaron a
la oposición vamos a hablar ahora
precisamente lo que se comenta las
elecciones a nivel gobernador estaban en
juego 15 gobernaturas yo recuerdo que
méxico es una federación hay 31 estados
más la ciudad de mexico cada estado
elige su gobernador en este caso de la
mitad de los gobernadores que estaban en
juego hasta los resultado con los
resultados que conocemos hasta el día de
hoy morena el movimiento de renovación
nacional es decir la organización de
lópez obrador reivindica la victoria en
11 de esos 15 estados o de una cierta
manera gobierna la mitad o tiene el
control de la mitad del país cómo
explicar precisamente que por un lado
pierde la mayoría con sus aliados
insisto bien con sus aliados en la
asamblea nacional en la cámara diputados
pero logra mantener e incrementar
sustancialmente la mayoría en las
gobernaturas como se explica esta
contradicción gaspar estrada
yo creo que no es no creo que sea tanto
una contradicción yo creo que más bien
eso permite dar un testimonio de la
implantación territorial de morena una
realidad política que no se había
traducido en realidades estatales porque
no había habido elecciones yo creo que
esto confirma el carácter realmente
nacional del partido un partido que de
hecho creció muy rápidamente porque su
primera elección federal fue el hecho en
el 2015 que ya había tenido buenos
resultados pero una elección donde era
un partido esencialmente con algunas
presencias regionales fuertes sin
embargo no era un partido de proyección
nacional su presencia era esencialmente
la ciudad méxico el estado de méxico
guerrero michoacán veracruz pero era
difícil ir más allá de ello y estas
elecciones del 21 lo que han demostrado
es este enraizamiento de morena en la
política nacional estados por ejemplo
como sonora sinaloa
que nunca habían tenido gobierno se
puede decir la izquierda pues van a
tener esta alternancia a colima por
ejemplo sin embargo lo que sí me parece
es que también existen estas decepción
de los electores hacia morena y eso me
queda queda en evidencia para mí los
resultados de la ciudad de mexico que es
una ciudad que eligió a alcaldes de
izquierda desde finales de los años 90
la primera alternancia se hizo hacia la
izquierda contrariamente lo que pasó en
el escenario nacional y eso me parece
que sí es un recado me parece que es un
recado claro de los electores una de las
cosas que ha llamado más mi atención
gaspar estado volveremos después solos
la ciudad de mexico que efectivamente es
fundamental para tener una lectura
correcta más o menos de lo que ha
sucedido en estas elecciones producía lo
que me ha sorprendido mucho es la el
bajo grado de política en el mejor
sentido del término de estas elecciones
hemos visto de todo una gran agresividad
hemos visto el clientelismo llevado a
sus extremos no lo más ridículo lo más
bajo cómo se explica que finalmente
dentro de los 21.000 candidatos
realmente haya gente que unos split se
pregunta pero cómo es posible que han
llegado ahí y sobre todo sabiendo que
había más de 700 millones de euros en
juego que lo que distribuyó el instituto
nacional electoral para que sus
candidatos hicieran campaña claro me
parece que ese es un elemento importante
que hay que constatar y que hay que
analizar es la degradación del discurso
político en en méxico y más generalmente
en américa latina'
infelizmente
hemos pasado de discursos de ideas y
debates bastante estériles con mucha
descalificación pocas propuestas y
también lo que se reflejó del debate
político general en méxico con un
presidente que usa muy bien la
plataforma de las conferencias de prensa
para comunicarse con sus electores pero
que también usa esta plataforma para
crear antagonismos y polarizar
el debate público y al hacer este tipo
de estrategia de comunicación pues
claramente es difícil que un debate
tenga un nivel elevado y que sobre todo
se puedan confrontar ideas aquí hay
mucha polarización y esta campaña estuvo
marcada por esa polarización tanto de
parte del gobierno como de parte de la
oposición y eso no es de buen augurio
para lo que viene en un momento en el
cual pues hay problemas de crecimiento
económico con una violencia cada vez más
presente lo vimos en estas elecciones
una vez más hubo candidatos asesinados
hubo problemas de violencia política y
desde ese punto de vista pues no ha
habido muchas soluciones que han sido
realmente propuestas por estos miles de
candidatos y eso pues es algo triste
para la democracia mexicana violencia
política exacerbada lo comentaba usted
más de 900 actos delictivos que fueron
registrados oficialmente más de 90
políticos asesinados 36 aspirantes 14
mujeres
el gobierno al final de cuentas decía
pero es muy poco osea subestimó
completamente esta situación no es la
más violenta de las elecciones en las
elecciones pasadas los masas candidatos
asesinados pero es una gran señal de
alarma que tendría que sonar pep al
gobierno me parece que sí me parece que
sí infelizmente no es un fenómeno
reciente la violencia política en mexico
infelizmente data de hace mucho tiempo
atrás sin embargo el gobierno debería
tomar cartas en el asunto ya sea sea
protegiendo a los candidatos en
particular en elecciones locales
pero también asegurando el derecho a la
información y el pluralismo también ha
habido muchos casos de periodistas
asesinados amenazados durante este este
último año y durante este proceso
electoral y de nueva cuenta si no se
toman cartas en el asunto si no se
imaginan nuevas maneras de abordar estos
asuntos claramente vamos a seguir en lo
mismo y eso infelizmente es algo que me
parece que ha caracterizado el gobierno
de lópez obrador que en
enarbola y defiende su idea de cuarta
transformación sin embargo lo que hemos
visto en los últimos tres años en mexico
es mucha continuidad continuidad en la
política económica e inclusive atrás a
pesar de la pandemia el gobierno no
propuso una reforma fiscal importante
para poder aumentar la recaudación
pública o ir a los mercados
internacionales de deuda para financiar
para políticas sociales pero también
continuidad en lo que tiene que ver con
las políticas de seguridad con un
ejército cada vez más presente en las
acciones de lucha contra el crimen
organizado entonces desde ese punto de
vista pues hemos vigo poco originalidad
en las políticas gubernamentales de las
dos principales preocupaciones de los
mexicanos se puede decir que ruptura no
ha habido vamos a ver porque el tiempo
va muy rápido
gaspar usted ha comentado precisamente
la situación de la ciudad de mexico un
pilar que fue el movimiento morena el
propio presidente en las elecciones del
2018 morena se había llevado 22 de los
20 y 23 de los 24 distritos la situación
ha cambiado radicalmente ahora se ha
partido la oposición la remató 12
distritos
al movimiento morena quedado la parte
oeste de la ciudad completamente en
manos de la oposición la parte esté en
manos de morena ese es un golpe se ha
derrumbado el partido oficial y del
oficialismo la ciudad de mexico si eso
me parece que si es un dato real y
políticamente relevante porque el
partido el movimiento de lópez obrador
tiene como base la ciudad de mexico
buena parte de su legitimidad política
surge de la ciudad de méxico durante los
casi 13 años en los cuales lópez obrador
no tuvo un cargo público del 2005 cuando
salió de la jefatura de gobierno la
acción de gméxico hasta el 2018 cuando
fue electo presidente de mexico entonces
ese punto de vista que creo que si hay
un recado claro ahí de los electores y
en particular de esta base electoral lo
cual va a complicar este diseño del
segundo mandato del presidente lópez
obrador teniendo en cuenta que alguna
parte del mando la segunda parte del
mandato de lópez obrador teniendo en
cuenta que tanto claudia sheinbaum la
actual alcaldesa de la ciudad de mexico
y el canciller marcelo ebrard pues
tienen responsabilidades compartidas en
una parte del central de esta campaña
del 2021 que fue el la caída del
derrumbe
una estructura del metro que causó
conmoción en el país y la
responsabilidad es compartida y como
estos dos personajes son dos de los
principales precandidatos a la
presidencia está claro que esto tendrá
una consecuencia política para morena y
para el presidente nos quedan 30
segundos gaspar a estrada la pérdida de
la mayoría toma mayoría cualificada en
la cámara diputados que decir que vamos
a hacer un bloqueo probablemente de la
situación probablemente de manera muy
muy breve yo creo que no porque
concretamente el gobierno puede aprobar
el presupuesto puede aprobar la mayoría
de las reformas que se quiere hacer pero
no habrá reformas de gran calado
perfecto pues llegamos ya al final de
esta escala en parís no me queda sino
agradecerles a gaspar a estrada director
del opal que el observatorio político
para américa latina y el caribe su
presencia gracias gaspar
a ustedes le damos otra cita en otra
próxima escala en parís la semana
entrante
[Música]
[Aplausos]